When you browse for the latest dating apps, have you stopped a little and wondered
"Why many people have a beautiful appearance of harmony?"
Well, it turns out there is a simple explanation for this phenomenon.
If we make a diagram showing the relationship between kindness and beautiful appearance, we can show the answer.
First, we have to assume that people are distributed equally across this scheme.
In other words, some people here are ugly and ugly
Some people are ugly and kind
Some are beautiful looking and lame,
Some are nice looking and nice!
Of course, this depends on your personal taste and what you see beautiful or ugly.
Now: when you think about it, your interest is probably zero for people you find to be bad and ugly
Which means that your probability circle has become smaller.
Frankly, you may prefer a specific combination of beauty and kindness.
In the end, we left a group of people who found them acceptable and showed interest from the beginning.
But now, 100% of the people who stayed in the group who do not find them attractive
They are nice
They have to be, otherwise you will not be interested.
After all, if a person is nice, your criticism will probably decrease,
Lowering your average beauty standard.
Similarly, nearly half of the people you find beautiful are harmonious.
Similarly, if a person is a person,
You will probably need to be very attractive to you to give them any attention,
Making it seem as if all the people are attractive
They are harmoniously.
If we look further we can assume that people who are beautiful and nice of luck are present
And disappear from the market quickly,
Increasing your awareness and bias.
We can see something similar to this for food
Have you ever wondered why the taste of healthy eating does not seem delicious?
Well let's use our chart
Pleasure versus health
Of course, in fact, foods will not be distributed equally in the scheme,
Because food is usually made to be savory,
So the right part of the chart will look more dense.
Regardless, we can remove all foods that have no taste or even benefit for you
The reason - why bother to eat them?
But among the foods that I have eaten and eaten,
Now 100% of non-tasty food is beneficial to you!
Just as in the dating scheme,
It is only because of people or food
Which does not give him any attention you have become distorted.
Referring to dating, this is true.
From your point of view, people with a beautiful appearance are likely to be harmonious -
But because of who gives him attention from the beginning!
You simply ignore the ugly harmony.
Special thanks to Blue Apron for their support of this episode,
The first 300 people registered at our link were given 3 free meals at their first request.
Blue Apron allows you to create recipes prepared by chefs,
By delivering fresh agricultural ingredients to your home stacks ready for cooking!
It's a simple and fun way to try new recipes every week,
And take your time less than 40 minutes to make it instead of doing the same old thing.
You can access the cooking by using the link in the description.
Subscribe to the channel for more scientific sections weekly Translation: team translate autrjim @